Butterflies. Beautiful. It isn't that
crazy. Orange and black like we love them.
Love them. You find a
spider. You stomp it.
You would never go to a zoo and go into
the moth house. If you kill a lady bug,
you're an asshole. Oh, completely. You're
a type of person who kills lady bugs.
Yeah,
but if you don't kill Roach,
I can't hang out with you because you let
a roach run across your kitchen floor.
You like sod nom roach,
sadness. I save all.
Kill that fucking thing. You got
a roach in your kitchen, lady?
Yeah.
A lady has little couple dots on it.
Why are we racist with bugs? Because
there's such a thing as beauty. Okay.
That's why I squirrels get a pass and
rats don't. Yes. Bushy tail. Yeah.
Looking Kewill style,
like a fringe jacket.
She's a tail was just because they found
that if the tails group bushy people
would stop killing them. Yeah. I mean,
what's more disgusting than just a
skin tail with nothing on it. Awesome.
Awesome. Tail possums don't
even causing any problems.
They just see us doing possum.
Taylor do you little fucking get you bat.
We'll give a little that little hands
and your little reptile tail create a
little beady eyes. Disgusting. Yeah,
but like we have certain animals
that we liked like raccoons. Look,
we don't wreck like raccoons and they're
eating out of your garbage button. No.
If someone had a pet raccoon, you would
think that's the dopest thing ever.
Can we have, we secretly
want relationships. Raccoons.
If they would only be nicer to us,
we would embrace raccoons.
Raccoons don't want to have shit to do
with us. They don't. I don't get it.
We got smart. We're too smart
for us. We're nice to them.
I'd like these people are assholes.
Just wait til they go to sleep and either
trash. We'll just eat their garbage.
Savory ether garbage. They put
lids on it. That shit doesn't work.
They've got the cool black mass. You
lift the lid, you throw it aside.
He pulled the bag out of hands.
I know if people and say to
the little tiny people, hey,
I know you can grab stuff. Smoke
cigarettes, hang out. Yeah. The text,
they also was kill
chickens. Well, so do we.
Do you know who's a real predator?
Skunks. Skunks are predators.
There's a skunk living in the back
of my yard. Whew. Sprayed my dog.
Oh No, it's still there.
I think so. Come on Bro.
Man Up. What am I going to do?
Take out the skunk hazmat suit.
He'd be gun time to go to war.
I got to go crawl under the thing and
find them crawling to the thing. He goes,
look at this fucking hand.
That shit's crazy.
It's like he's flaunting. He was
like, yeah, look at that, huh?
His hand is so much smaller than his face.
It's crazy.
Imagine if your hand was that small and
relationship is the size of your head.
He's adorable though, isn't he? He is cute
little fellow. I'm just like, look at,
look, you think I've stayed
out of your garbage? No Way.
Look what I'm working with.
Do they have opposable thumbs?
Because what I'm working with didn't
quite seem like now it's just like five
fingers with no thumb. Right. That's
the thing. They never figured out.
Look at his teeth. They never figured it
out like they had meetings as hands to,
we just need a thumb. Let me see the
teeth there. He's got his mouth open.
Your that. Whoa, that. Well that would
really hurt your fucking suck. Look,
one of them's chipped. If, uh,
yeah, from biting you in the head.
Do you think if a rocket attack
do you could fight it off? No.
What do you think you could stomp it?
What'd you do? What'd you give up?
It might cut your neck.
When would you decide we're going to
to the death immediately. Immediately.
He wouldn't try to talk to
raccoon out of this. No. Fuck off.
As soon as he makes a move.
I'm ready because I've been thinking
about it since childhood. Oh,
look at that one. I don't want that one
bite my nose. Yeah. Looks like a Hyena.
The raccoon I made that thing.
I've been thinking these things
are coming after us my whole life,
so if he makes a move, it's on, Bro.
Those teeth are God damn terrifying.
Yes. Look at those teeth now and
they're sneaky. That's a big thing.
And they're filled with rabies.
Filled. Yeah, to the top.
Like their balls are heavy with rates.
It's just oozing out of him
to water balloons. Raccoons.
Is it the sensus touch? Oh, I touched you.
When raccoons rely on their hands more
than their eyes and going through tachy
study suggested their sensitivity to
touch increases when their hands are wet,
which might be why they
always wash their food. Wow.
I just washed my hands and now I am
going to touch you when you sleep.
I ain't going to do you and your children
where he was sleeping with my finger
hand.